laureates and now a crucial backing from
the biden administration to waive
intellectual property protections
[Music]
critics including drug companies say
this plan won't help
and could even slow the global rollout
so what's the fastest way to vaccinate
the world
here's what you need to know
[Music]
developing countries are asking for a
waiver on intellectual property rights
in the vaccines
so they can either develop their own
vaccines or have access to cheaper
options
however unfortunately right now the eu
and its member states as well as other
rich countries are blocking this waiver
backed by about a hundred countries this
would entail waiving a key global trade
agreement
known as trips they argue that the time
limited waiver would promote
more manufacturing and a much faster
rollout of jabs
pharma companies are putting profit
not people first we need companies
to share all their research on the other
side however
opponents say it won't necessarily help
one argument is that waving patents
wouldn't make much of a difference in
the first place
they say this is because the capacity to
safely manufacture vaccines elsewhere
is far too limited the main
long-standing objection though
is that suspending ip rights would
remove the incentive for drug companies
to innovate
in the future in other words without ip
rules
drug companies wouldn't have good
reasons to risk billions on research and
development
we would also probably never have gotten
covert 19 vaccines so
quickly typically in vaccine development
it takes years because you're waiting
for fairly rare
events to occur which is infections of
the disease you're trying to prevent
we have experience in the messenger rna
field for
for more than a decade and and we have
technologies in place
which allows us to make to make vaccines
and evaluate vaccine can
candidates in a ultra fast fashion
critics however question one or both of
these arguments
campaigners and prominent economists
including mariana masacato
say that firstly intellectual property
rights were never designed for use
during deadly pandemics
and exceptions have been created in past
like penicillin during the second world
war
secondly it's not just ip protections
that may drive incentives to innovate
and produce
but government funding in the u.s six
vaccine companies have received about 12
billion dollars of public money
and a lot more historically for basic
research
this idea that somehow a time limited
patent waiver to deal with extraordinary
circumstances
would somehow stifle a future innovation
is very difficult to buy because there
are some
very deep fault lines in the way we
currently
fund our innovation systems the reason
why this makes sense
is the biggest driver of innovation
really
is need and necessity by imposing these
patterns we take away
uh this this key motivating factor from
poorer countries
the countries are poor they're not
incompetent when it comes to technical
innovation
um so we take away that blockage
and we allow a thousand flowers to bloom
thirdly they argue that manufacturing
capacity worldwide does exist and could
potentially add hundreds of millions of
doses to supply
but waving ip rules wouldn't make a
difference on its own
without the technology and knowledge a
waiver may be a non-starter
we must have a framework for the next
pandemic
world trade organization chief from gaza
konja iwala says there is a so-called
third way
she says companies should pursue more
licensing agreements to get
manufacturers on board
she also says companies should use
multilateral arrangements to share
technology and know-how voluntarily
but so far the latter hasn't really been
taken up
ideally we would like pharmaceutical
companies to be involved in that process
right
because for the licensing to take place
or to be
a part of the waiver would also involve
not just information that might be in
the patent application but also
technical know-how many of this uh
information that's necessary
might be commercially sensitive might be
held as straight secrets
might not be disclosed so ideally if we
want this to be done with a sense of
urgency we need these companies to
cooperate
if they're not going to cooperate then i
suggest governments support this viewer
and allow developing countries to do
their thing
drug companies on the other hand
maintain they are up to the task of
meeting the world's vaccine needs
and that it's other problems that have
slowed things down
they say the unprecedented nature and
scale of the pandemic
has created shortages of everything from
key ingredients
to tubes and plastics trade barriers and
restrictions they say
are also slowing down supply chains
nevertheless as capacity is ramped up
they say worldwide production could
reach 10 billion doses by the end of
this year
we are ready to discuss how
the us proposal for waiver on
intellectual property protection
for coveted vaccines could help achieve
that objective
in the short run however we call upon
all vaccine producing countries to allow
exports and to avoid measures that
disrupt supply chains
it's a tall task that the wto faces
quick takes mark daniel davies thank you
so much for that report
maddie let's get you some other
coronavirus news from around the world
the coven pandemic in
india showing no signs of slowing down
the country reported its highest ever
daily tally of more than
412 000 new cases and a record one day
death toll of nearly
4 000. india's government agreed to
provide more medical oxygen to hospitals
in the capital
and denies being slow in getting out
life-saving supplies
donated from abroad and olympic athletes
and delegations will be able to receive
coveted vaccine doses donated by pfizer
and buying tech
as organizers push ahead with
preparations for the delayed
games in tokyo this summer the
international olympic committee signed
an agreement with the companies to
donate the doses
with the first delivery expected to
begin at the end of this month
now the ioc has not made vaccination a
requirement for athletes participating
in the games
or for other workers who are going to be
on site as well
and russian authorities have given
approval to a single dose version of the
country's sputnik v
vaccine after it showed almost 80
percent efficacy
russia says the new vaccine called
sputnik light costs under 10
a dose and has been earmarked for export
and could increase the number of people
with partial immunity i can't imagine a
vaccine called vaccine light working
well in the u.s
now for the latest covenant news
bookmark bloomberg.com forward slash
chronovirus scarlett it's all about
branding right
right coming up after the break don't
call it a comeback except that it
kind of sort of is it turns out older
american millennials
those born in the 1980s came out of the
trump era in better financial shape
we've got the surprising numbers next
[Music]
[Music]
access the financial world on demand
[Music]
hear from leading economists
policymakers
and industry experts via live and
on-demand webinars
only from bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
our generation's biggest problem climate
change
is happening and the world's most
innovative solutions transport
industry buildings electricity
all of those things everything you need
to know about our changing environment
the politics of global warming we can
and we will deal with climate change
in the fight against climate change
bloomberg has you covered
[Music]
[Music]
millennials made a lot of financial
gains in the trump era but they're still
way behind where their parents were at
the same age
new data from the st louis federal
reserve bank show 30-something americans
saw their wealth gap with prior
generations improve
from 2016 to 2019 but as with so many
things these days the recovery has been
uneven
so let's bring in anna hernandez kent
she's a senior researcher at the st
louis feds institute for economic equity
anna welcome to quick take so you combed
through a lot of data on consumer
finances and you found that the typical
millennial family has seen improvement
over the past three years
at least before kovid i was really
surprised by this
get us started by telling us the key
numbers and what they show about
generational wealth
yeah thanks for having me scarlett and
uh just before i begin i want to say
these are my own views and not
necessarily
the fed um but essentially what we found
is that the typical millennial family
was about 40
behind in terms of wealth back in 2016.
but just three years later they had made
significant gains and were
only 11 behind after having nearly
doubled their wealth
so this is surprising what do we know
about why this happened
this improvement contrary to perhaps
popular belief in popular narrative
millennials are right on track with
older generations in terms of home
ownership and in terms of stock
ownership
over half of them have these assets
which have done pretty well
well in the past few years and for
millennials in particular it seems like
their home values have increased quite a
bit which is a large part of the story
okay got it there are also a lot of
surveys that show millennials feel a lot
more comfortable
talking about how much money they make
and how much they spend
certainly more so than gen xers or
boomers they often share numbers and
tactics with
each other often to redress uh gender
and
racial pay gaps do we know how these
older millennials close the wealth gap
from 40
to 11 in those three years um so as i
was saying i would say
um home ownership is a big part of the
story over
50 percent of older millennials are
homeowners um and their home equity
values have actually increased uh by
about twenty thousand dollars between
2016 and 2019. so that's a large part of
the story
as well as the fact that they are very
highly educated and so perhaps that
education is
finally paying off for some of them okay
does it have anything does
income play a role here so what we've
seen
is that income um at least for uh
graduates those with college degrees
seems to be holding pretty steady that
that college income premium but it
doesn't seem to be translating into
wealth gains in the same way so as i
said they are still somewhat behind even
if not
quite as much as they were before okay
that's the big picture though
but as we know the pandemic has created
this k-shaped recovery where the rich
get richer and the poor get poorer
and when you pull apart the data and you
disaggregate it and you look at it by
race
for instance black americans are still
pretty far behind
what kind of story does the data on
black americans tell
absolutely so my colleague and i little
ricketts that was by far our most
concerning finding which was that black
older millennials had about five
thousand dollars
in wealth or about half as much as we'd
expect them to have
based on older generations of black
americans
and not only that but they were falling
further and further behind
each year white millennials on the other
hand had about 88 thousand dollars in
wealth
which means that the racial wealth gap
in this generation
is astronomically large
so it's interesting here because you're
comparing older black millennials with
previous generations of black americans
as opposed to looking across
race so you're really comparing like
with like you mentioned education
earlier that's a huge part of the story
because millennials went to college at a
time when student loans
proliferated everyone was in debt and of
course college tuition skyrocketed as
well
what does the data on student loan debt
tell us about the specific burdens that
black millennials faced so
black millennial graduates those with a
four-year degree or more
are much more likely than their white
counterparts to have student loan debt
in fact
the majority of them about four out of
five do
and for those who didn't finish college
but maybe started in took out debt
about a third of them have that debt and
don't have the credentials to help them
potentially pay that debt off
yeah that's really really concerning
yeah absolutely so
these are the older millennials we're
talking about people who were born in
the 1980s
does the data on younger millennials
perhaps those that were born in the 90s
tell
a different story or is it pretty much
in line
um so far we've only been able to look
at the most recent
survey way for them those 1990s
millennials myself included
and that's i'm very eager to look at
that that decade
um but so far it is fairly concerning um
and as of the most recent 2019 data
we're
actually 50 behind wealth expectations
um but you know on average we're still
very very young and
it's early in our career so we have a
lot of time to catch up certainly more
so than
the older millennials do interesting how
much debt
do older millennials have overall i mean
we talk about student loan debt
of course as they get older and they
start buying houses
and they start living their lives the
credit card debt the auto loan debt
mortgages may start to replace some of
the student loan debt can you
give us a breakdown of the kind of debt
that they have
so uh just like older generations the
bulk of
millennials debt is in home mortgages
so uh roughly 60 or so of their their
debt is home mortgage debt
um and this can be potentially if it's
at the right time
and the right uh assets back it up it
can be a good kind of debt right it's
going towards an asset that is
appreciating certainly
um in the the last few months or so um
on the other hand the other types of
debt that you talked about um
vehicle debt credit card debts certainly
also make up
uh quite a bit of the remaining portion
of debt
uh and that's not necessarily going to
um
be a quote-unquote good type of debt for
for these millennial families
got it anna hernandez kent of the saint
louis fed really appreciate your joining
us and telling us about this and
hopefully
this is data that will inform
policymakers and decision makers
as well maddie millennials and wealth we
talk about that something else kind of
comes to mind as well
right it's a story that's not going
anywhere which is why starting today
we're giving you a daily
cryptocurrency check an update on the
digital currency space and we're
starting of course with
dogecoin the meme coin is down today
while bitcoin and ethereum are climbing
now it's a win for the doge haters who
say it's nothing but a joke
but doge loyalists who created this
image of elon musk you can see behind me
have a goal of getting the coins value
up to a dollar by the time musk hosts
snl this saturday
he's a big doge fan so people are
hopeful that he's going to mention the
coin
and drive up its value today's dip puts
it at roughly 60 cents per coin
and there's no dog in there right
there's no no dog no dog but they've got
a lot of other
doji imagery hidden in there elon's face
exactly
exactly and we're gonna get you some
other tech news from today say goodbye
to that photo crop on twitter
users rejoiced after the social media
platform announced a new feature
that allows photos to be displayed in
full on the timeline
now before they were cropped and that
often led to some awkward photo upload
moments
the new feature arrives as twitter is
also making users aware of potentially
harmful language
the site rolled out a prompt for english
language users forcing them to pause and
reconsider
using hurtful or offensive words in
their tweets
and google is making a major push for
security on world password day in a blog
post the company says
two-step verification will automatically
be added to
all user accounts now two-step
verification you typically have to
confirm from your mobile phone that you
are in fact the one that's trying to
sign into your google account
according to google searches for how
strong is my password
shot up 300 last year that's of course
his privacy concerns went up while
everyone was online during covid
and facebook says it's keeping up its
crackdown on fake accounts
the company pulled nine networks from
its various services last month
from six countries including mexico peru
ukraine azerbaijan
palestine and the central african
republic the report is part of an
ongoing effort against
coordinated misinformation from
non-government entities
for the latest tech news bookmark
bloomberg.com forward slash technology
scarlett coming up after the break
florida joins texas
and georgia as the latest state to
restrict voting so how will this affect
the swing state in upcoming elections
this is quick take
[Music]
access the financial world on demand
hear from leading economists
policymakers
and industry experts via live and
on-demand webinars
only from bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
this is the difference
[Music]
florida is now the latest state to
codify voting rights restrictions
into law republican governor ron
desantis signed into law a voting bill
which will limit access to mail-in
voting and put
stricter voter id requirements in place
among other things
republicans say this is all in response
to 2020 election fraud
though there are no serious signs of
voting irregularities
for more let's bring in bloomberg
government's jennifer k jennifer
thank you for being here i want to start
with the mail-in voting restrictions i
know this is a big deal for florida
because there are so many snowbirds who
aren't there in november so they
typically vote by mail
can you describe how that particular
restriction
is going to have an impact on voter
turnout in the state
well voters who want to vote by mail are
going to find themselves having to jump
through more
hoops to get those ballots and then
return those ballots in the next
election and that's kind of a gamble for
politicians here because
like you said voting by mail is really
popular
uh historically it was republicans who
are voting by mail the most in florida
but we saw that flip last year with more
democrats voting by mail
in november by a lot by like 680
000 votes so it'll be interesting to see
if voters find themselves
changing their voting habits or just
getting frustrated by the limits and the
new law
in 2022 that's a really important
election for florida republicans
because both governor desantis and
senator marco rubio will be up for
reelection
i want to put a pin in that and come
back to it but for now i know that
election officials do oppose this bill
and there's already a lawsuit against it
what's the likelihood of that lawsuit
having success and actually impacting
these restrictions
so there's actually now two federal
lawsuits challenging the florida law
that was a new development this
afternoon they were filed by the league
of women voters the naacp
and advocates for retired people and and
for florida
floridians with disabilities they're
hoping a judge will agree with them
and say that the law is unconstitutional
and disproportionately
affects people of color and voters with
disabilities
but if they're not successful election
supervisors are just going to have to
make these
new restrictions work within very
limited budgets
and so some are saying some activists
are saying that at least the florida
restrictions don't seem to be as dire as
the restrictions in a state like georgia
can you explain what the biggest
difference is between the restrictions
that we're seeing in both of these
southern states
and so florida lawmakers were saying
this too as they were working on the
bill
they made a point of saying this bill
isn't georgia 2.0
uh meaning that it's not as restrictive
when it comes to giving food or water to
voters
standing in line that's really important
in hot southern states
um but the thing is that the bills are
are still similar in that
florida and georgia republicans both
wanted to be even more restrictive than
they ended up being
they had to walk back those proposals
because of the opposition they were
getting from the election supervisors
and those initial proposals were things
like getting rid of the drop boxes
entirely or ending no excuse absentee
voting
and i want to dig into kind of how we
learned
about this bill getting signed into law
governor ron desantis gave fox news an
exclusive when he did that this morning
that's very unusual because typically
you allow lawmakers and
and other media outlets in on these
things what do you think his strategy
was behind
conducting this in this way well
governor desantis
said it himself today his fox news
appearance had a national audience
he's already being talked about as a
potential presidential candidate or
running mate in 2024 and in the meantime
he's running for re-election in florida
next year
so today's event looked a lot more like
a campaign rally than a typical
bill signing ceremony and the way he's
talking about this bill
makes it clear that he wants people in
other states who
believe that they've seen voter fraud in
those states
to see what he's doing in florida and
that he
has a zero tolerance policy for it so
jennifer i want to end where we started
which is
is this move by desantis going to end up
shooting him in the foot a little bit
because we know that last year more
democrats voted by mail but in the
history of florida it's typically more
republicans voting by mail so
what do you think this restriction is
going to do for him in a potential 2024
run
i think it's going to be motivating
either way if you're a voter who
believes in
the lies about widespread voter fraud in
the last election
then what desantis is saying might look
good to you and maybe you'll
think that jumping through the extra
hoops is worth it but it could also
really motivate the grassroots
organizers and the people doing
voter registration drives that we saw
play a really big role in the 2020
election
you have to assume that they'll be using
what's happening
in florida and georgia and texas to push
voters next year
jennifer really appreciate you joining
us to break down what's going down in
florida
thank you scarlett all right let's take
a look at stories making headlines from
around the world
we're going to start in columbia which
is recovering from a night of violence
which left 46 people injured
dozens of police stations destroyed
local media report
24 people died in ongoing protests that
began when thousands of colombians took
to the streets
to oppose a controversial tax reform
that has since been withdrawn
demonstrations continue with calls for
further reforms
over to germany now where catholic
priests across the country are defying
pope francis
they are preparing to bless gay couples
despite a recent vatican ban on the
practice
priests and lay ministers are planning
coordinated ceremonies to improve gay
relationships
in about 100 catholic churches in coming
days
this move is the latest example of how
far german catholics are willing to push
the boundaries of the vatican's
authority
and french fishermen starting to leave
the british isle of jersey
ending their protests over post-brexit
fishing rights
this after the uk and france deployed
military patrol ships to the area
representatives of the fishing fleet who
are upset at the conditions attached to
licenses needed to operate in the area
said they had made their point and will
now be returning to france
negotiations over fishing rights were
among the most contentious parts of the
post-brexit deal
for the latest news from your part of
the world go to bloomberg.com click on
the addition drop down right next to the
bloomberg masthead and
choose your region maddie and coming up
after the break economic recovery from
the pandemic is
leaving communities of color behind we
speak with one leader who's trying to
change that when we get back into
our generation's biggest problem climate
change
is happening and the world's most
innovative solutions
transport industry buildings electricity
all of those things everything you need
to know about our changing environment
the politics of global warming we can
and we will deal with climate change
in the fight against climate change
bloomberg green has you covered
[Music]
[Music]
access the financial world on demand
hear from leading economists
policymakers
and industry experts via live and
on-demand webinars
only from bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
black americans have never had an equal
ability to reap the benefits of business
ownership
when it comes to black businesses
building a supportive ecosystem it's
even harder a report by mckenzie shows
only four percent of black american
businesses survived the startup stage
it found that covid contributed to
forcing 41 percent of black owned
businesses in the u.s to shutting their
doors
and while about 15 percent of white
americans hold some business equity
only 5 percent of black americans do
jeff nelson is co-founder and cto of the
media company blavity which has now set
up a new
racial equity organization focused on
helping minority-owned businesses
jeff great to speak with you before we
talk about the non-profit arm of your
company i want to hear
about the origins of blavity these
efforts i i would sense are personal for
you because i'm sure you experience your
own
ups and downs when you started the media
company
absolutely well madison thank you so
much for having me it's a pleasure to be
here
to talk about what we're up to uh myself
and the other blabbity co-founders aaron
samuels
and morgan de blanc we all met in
college we went to washington university
in st
louis and we were all recipients of a
scholarship
and that scholarship gave us three
things that were instrumental
in helping us be successful at college
and beyond it gave us capital
community and connections and we all
sort of implicitly knew that but it was
a conversation
that we had in our early years of
building blabbity
as we were just remarking about how hard
it was for us to raise venture capital
uh being a company that was led by black
people and
who had a ceo that was a woman um and
just how hard it was
how hard and difficult it was to get
into some corporate doors to get
sponsorships for our events or
advertisers on our media brands and
we sort of remarked that we were very
fortunate to have a community
and connections and capital that
supported us early on and throughout our
journey through entrepreneurship
so we we set a goal to eventually start
a social impact
component to the business to do the same
for other founders
who look like us and that's what we've
done today with blabbity.org
yeah so tell me a little bit more about
blavity.org how it works and what your
mission is
so blabbity.org is a non-profit
uh that is founded by the three of us me
morgan aaron
and what we're doing today is we're
announcing our growth fellowship
we selected 12 fellows from across a
variety
of industries and what we're doing is
we're giving them ten thousand dollars
in non-diluted capital to help them grow
and scale their business
we're going to put them in a six-month
program that is going to give them
tools resourcing and coaching to also
grow and accelerate
as well we hope to roll out some
additional
programs uh in the coming months and
years but right now we're focused on
this growth fellowship because
we think that the most tangible thing we
can do to begin to attack some of those
disparities that you mentioned in the
intro
is to really put money into black
founders
and do it in a way that doesn't take
away from their ownership potential in
their companies
i'm i'm so glad you bring that up jeff
because one
thing that i find interesting when we
have these conversations is that
we're talking about what black
entrepreneurs and business owners can do
themselves but
it's a system that is really challenging
to work within i think about vc firms
where
you know they're led by a lot of white
men who are
looking to give that money and support
to people who look like them
so what do you think is the biggest
thing that could be done to break down
that system so it's multifaceted and you
mentioned vcs and one of the reasons i
emphasize the fact that
the funding we're giving to the fellows
in our cohort
being non-dilutive is because uh very
few black founders are eight relatively
speaking or able to raise vc dollars
uh but when they oftentimes they get bad
deal terms right because
uh when you're a black founder and your
options are so few
you really don't have a lot of leverage
in negotiation right so
uh black founders disproportionately get
bad
ideal terms when they do uh manage to
raise vc dollars and so
that's something that we want to address
as well right so how can we put
non-dilutive capital
into these businesses but more
importantly when we're working with
brands and corporations how can we get
them to understand that
you've got to patronize these black
businesses if you are looking for
vendors if you're looking
for artists or creatives or if you're
looking to partner uh
with individuals you should look to
these black entrepreneurs and these
black businesses
actually put revenue into those
companies because that's going to help
them
to improve their balance sheets and grow
in scale
i'm glad you bring that up too jeff
because earlier we were talking about
voting rights restrictions in florida
we're seeing that in georgia too
and corporations are starting to speak
out against those things
do you wish that these corporations
would go a step further and maybe put
their money where their mouth is and
like you said
invest in these black owned businesses
absolutely and i live in atlanta um so
i'm you know georgia
has been sort of a hotbed of political
activity
over the last several months and it's
it's great to live here because there's
so much activity and so much
needed discussion i do think
corporations have to put their money
where their mouth is
uh where they spend their dollars show
uh what they care about you know the ceo
can make a statement uh the marketing
team can do all sorts of campaigns but
if the dollars don't follow then it
rings hollow
just to give you a tangible example
blabbity's a media company uh
you know we have partnerships with a
number of brands to run ads on our media
sites and uh sponsor our events uh
that's a great opportunity for brands to
work with us and say
hey we want to show a black millennial
audience that we care and we're sincere
um and we welcome those opportunities to
work with brands and corporations
jeff nelson co-founder of blavity really
appreciate you joining us to talk about
this new venture thank you
scarlett let's get you to today's movers
and shakers the people impacting the
world of business politics and sports
hollywood power couple john krasinski
and emily blunt are in a paid dispute
with paramount pictures
over the studio's streaming plans for a
quiet place part two
their contract which is based on the
film's box office performance had its
theater run
cut in half from 90 days to 45. now the
move comes as paramount speeds up the
online release of paramount plus
which would of course reduce box office
receipts and pay for the actors
depending on how the dispute plays out
it could impact future contracts and pay
throughout the industry
details of one of the wealthiest
divorces shows melinda french gates
receiving over 2
billion of stock the past few days the
transfer comes from cascade investment
which is bill gates holding company
the most recent shift was for two of
mexico's biggest companies
coca-cola femsa and grupo televisa
tallying more than half
a billion dollars david swenson the
chief investment officer of yale's
endowment has passed away at the age of
67.
swenson pioneered how college endowments
are managed
shifting away from traditional funds
with stocks and bonds to favoring hard
to sell assets like private equity
this model paid off big time for yale
generating annualized returns of almost
11 percent from 2010 through 2020.
his impact lives on with some of the
wealthiest investors looking to
replicate his investment model
and kane tanaka the world's oldest
person at 118 years old
has pulled out from the tokyo 2020
olympic torch relay and the reason
coveted concerns the relay started in
march and it's been pretty rocky
six people helping with the tradition
have been diagnosed with coven 19
raising the case number for the event up
to eight
and those are your movers and shakers
coming up after the break
football tackles climate change the la
rams tells us how the team is helping
the environment
and cutting down on its carbon emissions
this is
[Music]
access the financial world on demand
hear from leading economists
policymakers
and industry experts via live and
on-demand webinars
only from bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
our generation's biggest problem climate
change
is happening and the world's most
innovative solutions
transport industry buildings electricity
all of those things everything you need
to know about our changing environment
the politics of global warming we can
and we will deal with climate change
in the fight against climate change
bloomberg green has you covered
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
it is never too early to talk football
every nfl team will typically play eight
to nine away games a season traveling by
bus or chartering flights which can
leave a pretty big carbon footprint
the los angeles rams are looking to
minimize their carbon footprint by
partnering with castrol
on a new environmental sustainability
program quick take's vanessa perdomo
spoke with the rams's chief operating
officer
kevin demoff about how the team plans to
do justice
so kevin can you tell me about this new
partnership between the rams and
castrol very exciting partnership and i
think one of the things when we built
sofi stadium in hollywood park
last year we really want to focus on
sustainability in terms of the design
uh the reclaimable water the entire
project in 300 acres and
you know castrol partnering with them
what allows us to do is not only focus
on
you know sustainability at home in los
angeles and englewood and hollywood park
but really as we travel throughout this
year with you know five long road trips
away from los angeles really offsetting
our carbon footprint
and partnering with keep america
beautiful to really make sure that we go
into every market we play in and leave
it better than we found it so
exciting work at home and throughout the
country in keeping america
beautiful that's great and
about the your initiative to reduce your
carbon footprint when
traveling how exactly uh are you
planning on doing that
so we're going to work with castrol
using their carbon calculator on their
website to calculate
you know the carbon offsets we have from
when we travel as a team and fly to away
cities our buses
and then work with castrol to basically
offset those and pay for those and then
along with that
when we travel we're going to pick up
one ton of waste in each visiting city
that we go to
and partner with the local community and
keep america beautiful to do that so
really what you're looking as it's
twofold
reducing carbon emission and cleaning up
the streets of the cities
that we go and visit as well as being
very cognizant of doing that here at
home in los angeles
and speaking of being at home in los
angeles this past few years the
california has experienced some
devastating wildfires
due to the effects of climate change has
that
affected your reasoning to do this
partnership and to get more involved in
the environment
well certainly as someone who grew up in
california native i remember you know we
would have fires and floods that's been
part of california but
never to the extreme that we've seen and
you know we felt the effects a few years
ago our entire practice facility
and uh office was shut down during the
woolsey fire
you know we were evacuated for two and a
half weeks you know
dozens of our staff lost homes you know
hundreds evacuated
and you see it every year the fires get
more devastating to hear the climate
change so
certainly anything we can do as an
organization to help you know california
improve
you know its microclimates you know its
atmosphere make sure that people here
are safe
and healthy and castro's been an amazing
partner in looking and tackling that
specifically here in los angeles but
obviously it's something we want to look
at across the country as well
absolutely so a lot of people would say
what does a football team have to do
with the environment
can you tell me why the environment and
sustainability is so important to the
rams organization
look i think it starts with leadership
in the community and
our job is not just to play football 17
times a year on sundays but really
to have community leadership you know
the other 348 days a year and what that
comes down to is
finding the causes that are important to
our players we've got a young you know
group if you look at our players their
average age is 25 26 they're going to be
on this planet a long time this is one
thing
you know that they do take meaningfully
in serious is making sure
that you know the climate whether the
planet's in a better place for them
in 30 and 40 years and for their kids
and their future generations
it's something that's personal to all of
us i think when we went and built
one of the world's largest stadiums at
sophie stadium you had to take a
sustainability lens
you know in a climate lens through it
otherwise you're not doing your part as
a good
corporate citizen when you build a 3.1
million square foot stadium that is
going to be
you know one of the amazing wonders of
the world is one of the amazing wonders
of the world
one of the first questions people are
going to think about is resources needed
to keep that building going
you know and you want to make sure that
sustainability is at the core of the
design the core of the project
and something you can be proud of when
you talk about sofi stadium
absolutely and so far stadium is phrased
for its innovation
and sustainability efforts so can you
tell me a little bit more about
what specifically when building that
stadium what the sustainability efforts
were
how important they were and what is the
carbon footprint
of sofi stadium compared to the other
older stadiums
well i think one of the first things you
look at in sofa stadium is the design
right a
stadium with no walls and a covered roof
so it
reduces the impact of heat inside but
also as a result we don't need
air conditioning or an hvac system to
blow through the entire stadium which
significantly reduces
the carbon footprint and the the climate
footprint and the energy footprint
of sofa city and then you look at over
11 million tons of recycled water a year
throughout the 300 acres
so far stadium is not just a football
stadium it's a 300 acre development with
housing
office space retail and entertainment
movie theaters and so it's making sure
that there are 25 acres of parks and
lakes there
a ton of greenery you know to eat up
that carbon footprint and also to make
sure
that it is sustainable when you have
reclaimed water throughout the project
cycling through nothing leaves the site
it all gets reclaimed so
it's a really amazing footprint in a
very urban area
to help try to beautify the space around
it in a dense urban footprint
that was quick takes vanessa perdomo
speaking with the ellie rams coo
maddie coming up after the break all
vaccine rollouts are not created equal
across the world
we'll find out what's being done to help
the most vulnerable populations on the
planet plan it
and we're going to be back in two
minutes
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
access the financial world on demand
hear from leading economists
policymakers
and industry experts via live and
on-demand webinars
only from bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
[Music]
[Music]
vaccines are just one tool to help
suppress the spread of covid but health
officials say
vaccine hesitancy could set back the
pandemic's end date
in some parts of the world people are
passing on the shots and others with
more vulnerable populations they just
don't have them to put this all into
context we are happy to welcome
un undersecretary general for global
communications melissa fleming
melissa thank you for being here we have
a lot we want to get to and i know my
co-host scarlett has a ton of smart
questions for you as well but first
paint a global picture for me of vaccine
hesitancy
what's the main thing that's stopping
people from getting this shot
well i mean it's combined with supply of
course i think right now
our biggest problem is lack of supply
our biggest problem is that the world's
rich countries
are vaccinating their populations like
crazy
and the richest countries in the world
have vaccinated 80 percent
um or have 80 of the vaccines and we're
seeing in the poorest countries
that you know some have not even don't
even have hope for a vaccine in this
year or even next year
so there's a lot of inequality in supply
and this is a problem we're hoping
that this can be resolved soon but it
coupled with that
um we're seeing in in in some places
enormous hesitancy in some communities
um
and in others it's really just that
holdout like here in the united states
where we're worried that this
percentage of people will prevent
the us from ever reaching the so-called
herd immunity
the vaccine supply is not the issue it's
just
the uptake that's going to be the
problem so it sounds like
globally the bigger emergency right now
is vaccine availability versus vaccine
hesitancy
i want to ask about verified which is an
initiative that the u.n rolled out last
spring
to deal and push back against
misinformation what are you doing
differently with verified now one year
into the pandemic
than before because priorities are
different depending on what region
you're looking at as we just mentioned
and there's obviously a different level
of
urgency in the rich world versus the
developed world or developing
absolutely absolutely you summarize that
perfectly um it's really shifted but
you know we started out with verified to
so you know kind of flood
the internet with science-based
information public health guidance that
people could use and to try to
fill those gaps where disinformation and
misinformation actors were trying to
dominate
this hasn't changed at all i the need
for
good public health guidance one year on
to this pandemic
is still there in a number of countries
so we're continuing
to put out those you know just very
basic pieces of information
on what to do to protect yourself from
the virus how to protect your community
it's really nothing has changed there
it's masks walking hands
social distancing but uh at the same
time
we are communicating very strongly about
vaccines uh
we do need to communicate to build
confidence in the vaccine and it is a
miracle
um that we have this safe and effective
vaccine
and several of them in such a record
time
the real fundamental problem as we said
before
is is supply and making sure the entire
world gets vaccinated or we're never
going to end
this pandemic so i hear you saying
supply is the issue but we also you know
like you said here in the u.s the
hesitancy is a real problem that we're
seeing continue
and one way to entice people to get the
shot is to remind them that life will be
more normal after they get it but
in the u.s again people feel like their
lives are already kind of normal if they
haven't been following the cdc
guidelines
so what do you wish people who are
saying i'm going to skip the shot
because my life is already good to go
what do you wish they unders understood
about how getting the shot
affects more vulnerable populations
around the world that
don't have access to the shots yet well
that's right i mean
it it it does mean that here in the u.s
and uh certainly because we're not going
to stay
an island forever everywhere else in the
world
that we will not end the pandemic if
there are not enough people who
will take the vaccine what does that
mean
i mean there are people who believe that
they're immune from it or
that it's not going to be so devastating
for them
but i think it's important to
communicate how devastating it is
potentially for others and that you can
be a carrier if you're not vaccinated
of the virus you could be hurting other
people you could be giving it to other
people and
as a consequence as a consequence other
people could die but
there's no cookie-cutter way to speak to
the vaccine
hesitant you know people have legitimate
fears
legitimate concerns so we're really
trying to mobilize
trusted messengers this is the best way
um to convince people um you know
members of the community doctors
right pharmacists um you know local
local celebrities uh to to really
deliver that message so at the same time
uh
you're talking about vaccine
availability and u.s and others have
been slow to share their vaccine patents
and that's now starting to change of
course but even so developing countries
getting access to that ip still will
struggle to get the supplies and the
manufacturing needed
to develop those vaccines and get them
out so what do you think is the single
biggest thing the developing nations
need right now to be able to get
access to more vaccines right well it's
a combination and this really was
a breakthrough to have the us
agree to um you know to allow
a sharing of information about the
vaccines with
uh potential manufacturers in other
countries and poorer
uh countries so that could be a game
changer in
supply um in you know around the world
so we're
really welcoming that at the same time
we have
um this international facility w.h.o
gabi that's called kovacs and it is
functioning um in you know well over a
hundred countries
uh it is there on the ground working
with the un
system unicef who ready to deliver
vaccines health systems short up
everybody the readiness is there
again it's a question of supply so if
more countries could share
excess doses if we could get more
donations
to kovacs so that more vaccines could be
purchased
we could go a long way towards shifting
this inequality
of vaccine um supply around the world
and also
ending the pandemic uh some any you know
in the near future
melissa this is a great conversation in
our final minute here
i know you spent 10 years at the u.n
high commissioner for refugees so you
got to keep a close eye on the world's
69 million refugees and displaced people
um give us an update on the trajectory
of covet cases in places like syria and
other areas of conflict
very quickly here well yeah this is this
is of course extremely worrying these
are areas where the
where people are um already in in
desperate situations
uh poor poor hygiene very
struggling um just to feed themselves
and to shelter themselves so it's
extremely difficult to reach them with
the
the measures that are needed and also
the health care that's needed
just one thing to say though it's very
some good news perhaps
i think over a hundred and in 30
countries have agreed
to to also include refugees and their
vaccinations